and for mike fultonevich we'll take a
look at his season
statistics he's started nine times
trying to lower that era a little bit
good strikeout to walk ratio his walks
are 2.4 per nine innings that's the
lowest for a ranger starter
this one pumped up on the infield might
be a one two three inning
for faulty brock holt is right there in
foul ground and it's an
eighth pitch top of the first for mike
fulton christian javier on the mound for
the astros javier three and one a three
point two seven era in eight starts
44 innings 28 hits 15 walks 53
strikeouts
swinging a miss got him to swing through
a pitch up
that's the first strikeout for javier
went away in the first they got him with
the slider up
that was actually the pitch that got him
ahead in this count was a slider early
you can see that thing spinning at the
top of the zone and solag didn't know
what to do with it
swinging a miss the runner on the go we
gotta strike him out throw him out
double play to end the inning
nice play fellas christian javier
bounces back from a 3-0 count to strike
out nate lowe and calhoun
gunned down easily by the machete so
tucker is the astros first base runner
and a third of first base
they got him picked off and uh tucker is
tagged out
he slipped as he started to get back and
he was a dead duck
for the pickup by fulton ends the inning
we just had what we call a quality foul
ball a moment ago
one two pitch this one on the ground
shortstop counter falafel goes to second
to take care of maldonado and the inning
is done another scroll is frame
here's the 1-2 got him swinging strike
three
on a tailing fastball that time from
holt couldn't reach it
and there's two away that's his third
strikeout
swing and a miss got him for the final
out of the third inning
two strikeouts in the inning for javier
both starting pitchers through three
no hits and two walks each eight hits or
more
for 19 in a row and they have not found
their first hit in this game yet
1-0 to michael brantley there is a line
drive to center field and there is the
astros first hit
tk called it michael brantley a two out
base runner
first hit of the ball game for either
side brantley
has now a seven game hit streak here's a
swing and a ball
lofted into right center field joey
gallo on the move to his right is there
makes a leaping grab
don't know as though he needed to do
that but boy it sure looked nice and
that'll win the top of the fourth inning
slider on the ground towards correa
carlos
knows solac is going to be flying up the
line so a quick transfer to get nick
and there's one away here in the fourth
good play by carlos
catching that on the run and throwing on
the run with a good strong arm
so one down here in the ranger half of
the fourth nate low coming up
here's a line drive over guriel and into
right field a base hit for nate lowe
tucker over to get it he gets there
quickly
and fires it back in altuve throws it
back to guriel and quickly hustling back
to the bag
with a long single is nate lowe so nate
won for two as he gets that one just
beyond the outstretched glove
of yuli guriel runners it first and
second with two men out now for isaiah
connor philippa fastball driven and it's
caught by altuve on the line tyner
paletta hit it right on the screws but
right out of tuve
and that's the third out of the inning
they strand two
2-2 swing and a miss fulton mibits pull
the string
threw a straight change up there at 86
miles an hour to uh with
mccormick that is the first strikeout
for
fulton ivic and slowly hit towards the
middle of the time and withdraw
speed all solace can do is glove it on
the backhand
astros have their second base hit of the
game a little tapping
in field hit for miles straw faulty
ready and comes home and there's a swing
and a drive to center field
garcia racing over toward left center
makes a running catch
to close out the inning oh if ever there
was a big pitch
in this game you figure this
is it holt and heim lead
the payoff and that is ball four
they are loaded on three straight walks
base is loaded for nick
solac 1-2 did he go around on a breaking
ball away
he did says ryan addison and that's all
for nick solak attitude making the call
from behind the plate
and a big strikeout for christian javier
his fifth two out so for the first time
in his career
javier allows more walks than strikeouts
brooks rayleigh will be on in a big spot
bases loaded two outs to face nate lowe
3-2 and that one misses bull four
so the rangers get the first run of the
game on a bases loaded
walk in the fifth another 002
swinging and a miss chased a high cutter
and the inning is over
but the rangers get a run thanks to four
astros walks
including one to low with the bases
loaded
chomping ground ball gets by brock holt
holt has had some issues defensively
this series that was a tweeter that got
through him and now tubey's going to
reach we'll wait to see how this one
scored
altuve running little bouncer up the
middle solak fields it on the bag for
one on the first
and he just pulled low off first base
that was about to be a really
spectacular double play
bregman short lead and the pitch is
lined to right field
in comes the right feeder gallo he's got
it this side's retired a hard hit out it
ends the inning
and the shutdown inning has been
accomplished by mike
foltenevich
a little bunt by gallow and fielded by
raleigh
the first night of time and joey puts
his way on
to start the bottom of the sixth yeah i
think
raley's best chance was to let it roll
might have stayed fair but he didn't
have
much of a chance to get him by picking
the ball up
and it's great idea by joey you've got a
left-hand pitcher on the mound you got a
close game
good punt here's izzy oh for two
and he lines one toward right it's a
base hit beyond the dive of el tobay
gallo stops at second and the ranger
leading one to nothing if two men on
with nobody out
gallow at second connor falefa at first
enfield shaded to pull
the o2 and that is strike three call on
the inside corner froze him with a
slider dahl can't believe it
swinging a miss got high this time
strands two runners on second
and third outfield slight shade to right
field infield
very much straight away against straw
and strike three called
on the 20th pitch of the inning fulton
evac rings him up
straw having words can't argue that
pitch that's all the way in the strike
zone
that's uh he just missed a good pitch
that's all
he was caught stealing in the first
inning on a strike him out throw him out
double play to in the inning
and then was left out there in the fifth
and he hits his ball into right field
back to base hit
calhoun just keeps on trucking at home
well he is really comfy in the batter's
box in general but especially here at
home
and nick show like the matter oh there
goes calhoun what a jump
and the ball smashed out to right field
carrying well
back to the wall and that will run hop
defense
here comes calhoun he'll score on the
double by
solo great base running in a ball well
struck
and it's two nothing base hits have been
kind of hard to come by
in this game hard hit balls have been
hard
to come by gets a slider away and goes
to right center field with it
and drives it quite a situation here for
brett martin bases loaded
one out and brantley coming up first
pitch inside and that goes to the
backstop almost hit brantley here comes
a run as castro slides in ahead of the
tag
by martin and the astros are on the
board
it's two to one rangers boy that pitch
almost hit brantley
three and two to brantley ground ball
right side altuve coming home
botched by solak but he gets the out
altuve probably would have scored either
way they get the out at first and altuve
ties the game with a run scored on the
rbi ground out by brantley
the astros knotted up at two tenth
inning astros and rangers tied at two
there's a line driving to center field
that'll be down for a base hit castro
being held
jose altuve with back-to-back hits
putting the astros on the corners with
nobody out
boy you hold the astros right here first
and third nobody out to no runs
that's some kind of pitching this one
out to center field and garcia leaps up
to grab it
and that will end the inning nick solank
is the zombie runner at second
one two that one on the ground second
base it'll move the runner up
now duvet throws out low but solac now
is 90 feet away
the winning run down there at third base
with this guy coming to the plate
and this one up the middle smothered by
altuve the throw will make it and the
rangers win it
and again it's a bumby
who drives in the winning run and the
rangers take it three to two and ten
so all you have to do is get the run in
doesn't have to go over the fence to do
it
and the dollar's got it done again that
is the first sweep of the astros since
2016 for the rangers